wer weiß schon freunde buch
er weiß schon heute wo wir morgen sind
wir morgen wieder alles neu beginnt
wir haben ein zelt mit 3000 sitzplätze
drin
wir haben die meisten tiere unterwegs
die meisten angestellten die meisten
artisten
personen die 400
ich bin verantwortlich für den ablauf
dass alles glatt laufe und keine
irgendwie fehler unterlaufen
sie sind derjenige der die manege
reingeht
künstler an sagt ja das mag ich circus
krone ist das richtige volkstheater noch
die tiere
die akrobaten
es ist noch vor sehr groß
so wir sind hier im circus krone ist war
gerade eine fantastische show und jetzt
schauen wir uns einfach mal hinter den
kulissen wird
schon geputzt kommt rein
ich habe gehört du kannst mir ein
bisschen hier was zeigen zehnten comcom
mit wein das ist mein motto
kostüme hier macht meine schminke so
hier unten habe ich meine schuhe
wie wird man klauen
ich habe angefangen als kleines kind
mein vater er war klar mein opa war
cloud also du bist im zirkus groß
geworden
wenn du schon so lange auftritt ist es
schwierig immer gleich lustig zu sein
ist nicht schwer ich bin wirklich
schön ist anders
aber klar ist auch gekommen
hallo das war vorgesehen heute morgen
ok dann weitermachen
und gut aufpasst wird keine zauberei
tradition bleibt tradition die leute
kommen mehr zurück zum zirkus weil das
ist ein richtiger live show heute zu tag
alles ist playback alles special effects
alles ist irgendwie verdeckt zirkus ist
noch was war das
es gibt kein ehrlicher spektakel kann
man sagen als sehr gut